i want another one i would have another
one now but
i i'm enjoying putting out music and i'm
gonna put out music the rest of the year
and i want to have a baby next year
kelly rowland is pregnant with baby
number two
the 39-year-old singer debuted her baby
bump on the cover of women's health
magazine
and inside the mag she and her hubby tim
weatherspoon
reveal they're expecting their second
child later this year
the couple who tied the knot in 2014
already share a five-year-old son
titan i think that overwhelmed me
was probably how much i didn't know how
much i was just gonna love this little
person
the singer tells the mag they'd been
talking loosely about expanding their
fam
and she admits that she was initially
hesitant to share the happy news during
such
troubling times quote you still want to
remind people that life
is important and while kelly and her man
are so excited
about their upcoming bundle of joy the
songstress admits she did have one
concern after finding out she was
expecting
quote i was thinking oh my god my fans
are going to be so disappointed
they wanted an album first but they got
a baby i have to figure this out so they
get both
as for that fifth solo album kelly says
it will be
very organic
the inspiration from coffee just really
comes from
um just really being in tune and tapped
into
your sexuality without being apologetic
for it
as for the second pregnancy kelly says
it's been
totally different than her first
explaining that she's been hit with an
overwhelming sense of exhaustion that's
left her unable to work out like she did
when she was pregnant with titan
as a result she says she's turned to
yoga walking and stretching with the
help of a physical therapist
and one thing's for sure kelly has a
great sense of humor when it comes to
being a mom
back in 2017 kelly wrote a parenting
guide
i really want moms to feel comforted and
i want them to have the knowledge
and so that they feel prepared they're
not just wandering aimlessly
the title whoa baby a guide for new moms
who feel overwhelmed and freaked out
and wonder what the [ __ ] just happened
the one piece of advice
i would give is to not to be so hard on
herself
i think as a new mom you just kind of
have this thing to where you feel like
you just have to figure everything out
for
yourself i would say ask for help if you
need it
i would say and when i say help i mean
like people around you
like can you watch the baby for like 10
minutes i just need to take a shower
don't be afraid to ask for help but
and don't be afraid to take out time for
yourself
in the mag kelly also opens up about
raising black children in the current
political
and social climate recalling how she had
a
hard ugly deep cry one night after
putting her son to bed
i promised to protect my kid that was
the main thing i was thinking about
protecting this little innocence there's
so many
things i'm feeling like everyone else
back in may
kelly opened up about the racial
injustice in the u.s
and revealed how her son helps her to
keep up the good fight
i can't sit still
i'm angry i'm hurt
um at times feeling hopeless
but then sometimes like i look at my
center and i'm like hell no i gotta keep
going